closer makes it possible for a function
to have private variables that's the
only time I've ever found w3schools
useful if it can have private variables
I can have stateful functions it's a
stateful function in the sense that as
every time I call it there's some
internal State going on that's being
mutated and you can see the result of
that the problem with this is that the
full variable is on the global scope so
any intermediate script can just mess
with it I can just say like food 999 and
that screws up my expectations of what's
supposed to happen so I need to protect
this variable somehow and move it off
the global scope and how do I do that I
move that inside the scope of the
function right and so now JavaScript
just refuses to run but I give up the
statefulness what I can do is return a
function inside of the function and do
the exact same thing inside there I'm
just going to switch this to a get add
function and now it still works again I
have my stateful function back and I
cannot touch Foo inside internally no
one else can access it but add can
access it every time is executed that's
closure